ma perchè queste smidollata zia
l'audience devi tenere la faccia [ __ ]
eva gt ragazzi che vede che sono io sono
farisei e fantastico che non ho mai
cambiato fissa in 3d 12 anni divide
questo videogioco che state per vedere
lo ha fatto ho giocato circa tre o
quattro anni fa più o meno è stato uno
dei primi video del canale ea distanza
di quattro anni ho deciso di giocarla
sta minkia taqwa che mi aveva fatto
girare abbastanza le palle ai tempi
spiega ragazzi che ogni cosa consista la
prima inter magari o alcuni di voi avevo
già visto il video vecchio l'avete visto
vuol dire che mi conoscete da quattro
anni e se mi conoscete la 4 anni avete
dei problemi seri io devo cliccare sulla
tastiera le lettere corrispondenti per
alzare il braccio e farlo attaccare
all'anello corrispondente io vi giuro
vive lo giuro nessun compito di
aritmetica avanzata o di algebra
nucleare potrà mai essere difficile
quanto questo videogioco perché porca di
una eva lercia incastrata nel divano per
attaccarsi ad uno listi cosi sembra che
tu debba soffrire tanto quanto un malato
di lettera angosciante perché porta di
una vacca non so se ti smidollato sto
tizio selena gomez qua dietro ragazzi
pian piano io prenderò più o meno il
ritmo è la cosa che pian piano nel senso
neuro sei partite non farmele pesare le
cose zio dai che ce la fai un che chi è
chi ha inventato suo gioco deve morire
con tutta la sua stirpe inventato questo
gioco devo avere del tempo libero ma
tanto è parecchio e io devo averne
veramente tanto per giocarci ancora di
più considerando il fatto che non riesco
a fare neanche un metro madonna di chio
quanto edifici sto gioco
e se tu cerchi gip che il nome del gioco
su google a fare giri profilo sapete che
vi mettono le informazioni di google dei
giochi a destra rimettono gip ecc e la
mia faccia la mia sclerata su sta merda
è stata riconosciuta in tutto il mondo
grazie ragazzi questa volta è diverso
questa volta ci devo riuscire perché ho
la forza di selena come cast cosa dai da
zzz siamo arrivati a 3 metri se dio
vuole fantastico v perfetto ma come
farsi le seghe zio facile sul noi
bravissimo ad elica non sei un
deficiente se vuoi credo che non sia
proprio il massimo per il tuo fisico
quello che sta succedendo adesso porca
vacca non c'aveva vendette che sfiga
schifosa laida che attenzione attenzione
voi cosa ho preso
no non ci credo sono dette madonna che
non so tenerli sulla tastiera il
parkinson decorosa questa cosa
indecorosa sono 20 anni che gioco e
videogames e no 22 quindi fatevi due
cariche sono sette anni che faccio video
su youtube e in sette anni dg di video
su you tube in vent'anni videogiochi non
ho mai trovato un videogioco fi
squallido di questa merda ci sono le
volte in cui dovrei saltare quindi
staccare il mio braccio destro in questo
momento volete cambiare si prova che se
non la prendo finiscono nell'oblio out
io posso sentire l'orgasmo quando
affermi qualcosa zio un orgasmo dello
giuro non posso in cinque anni essere
peggiorato sa già che c'era il piccione
michele se ci divertiamo ragazzi che vi
presento il piccione quel kakà palle
incredibili non si tocca zio dino mi
toccava neanche mia mamma quando ero
piccolo quello schifoso che caga sui
cornicioni e non solo si posa su queste
cose bellissime rendendomi impossibile
ditemi voi se non deve eliminare la seco
mischiato il gioco dove sparare
io c'ero anche il cane ecco quello gioco
della del secolo
porca eva un calcio in bocca altro che
di bala de vitoria zio ti devi modugno
di quello da tre ragazzi qualcuno sa che
comunque sa cucinare i piccioni per
cortesia mi fa salire il nazismo ma
guarda lì ma che schifo di essere ma non
è che doveva mettere sull'arca quel
giorno non potrà giocare scopa come
tutti i vecchi del mondo lo devo fare a
calci per farlo andar via vi rendete
conto
cavalca ax j ax subliminale sharleen se
si levasse sto schifo di essere volatile
guarda dove si va a mettere guarda dove
si va a mettere un calcio che dio santo
intravena 3 crossbar challenge madonna
speriamo che quando pio la patente voi
non rilevate dalla strada con l'accelero
perché una donna di dio ve lo giuro
da lì dove ci mette ok occhio l j j la
mia lettera zio lj sono le mie due
lettere non mi deluderà adesso fra dai
zio impegnativa tese ma devo andare
avanti tanto sto piccione non puoi
andati sotto cosa cambia attaccarti un
anello sopra attaccarti un anello sotto
attaccati al car agazzi siamo quasi a 20
metri che segnerebbe un record mondiale
per la madonna che hanno fatto vvf vi
prego non guardate questo video perché
sto imprecando contro un piccionne list
augurandole peggio malattie di satana ok
dite che dovevamo bula bula gruppo non
ci arrivo a fare 40 metri che vita
sociale avevo quattro anni fare ha poi
non metterti dove devo andare io puoi
portarti a destra lurido schifoso
animale guardando i guardano e si mette
guardalo tua guarda dove si mette il
cretino guarda lo slang sul dio santo
benedetto datemi un fucile ma data
ammazzo ti ammazzo
oddio
benedetto non ci posso credere di vita
non sulla k non saltare ma donata una
sola madre poi sulla j
vai sulla genitori charlie kid
sociologici arrivi adesso ci sono anche
i buchi nel muro vanta come se non
bastasse guarda lido si è messo tutta
qui non posso anche di alzare la mano se
si mette in questo appello a [ __ ] poi
non metterti sulla j grazie te ne sono
grato comunque ragazzi da chi all'inizio
non riuscivo a fare neanche uno
significa che colpo di testa zidane da
che non riusciva a fare neanche uno
siamo passati che sono 26 metri e mezzo
è un rilievo devo fare il doppio per
battermi record per ora il resto non mi
ricordo bene che conteranno record sera
41 sera tipo 50 lo vado a vedere quando
fin quando cado nella taglio so che di
base almeno a 40 41 ci sono arrivato non
posso mettere in pausa per andare a
vedere perché come mollo le dita dalla
tastiera
questo fa una brutta fine quindi non
posso mi spiace demonio
ragazzi siamo a 37 m 37 metri
incredibile sono con noi nel modo giusto
per andare avanti così bravo zio
perfetto l'agenda jane e jake potere
visto la gente 39 40 e tre non ci posso
credere a cosa divertente ragazzi
coordinato sushi tipo 20 minuti faide
una ventina di minuti che sto
registrando e la cosa fantastica che non
posso mollare la tastiera quindi se mi
arriva il sushi come cazzo faccio ma
porca vacca ma che problemi hai della
madonna di giugno selena guarda scusa
mincio proprio mimì saldamente
[Applauso]
no no no signori ok kkk come devo
studiare male spero che ci facciano un
giubbotto con le tue penne
non lo so non mi è un insulto peggiore
per un piccione mie mappe
no non devo fare quello che penso che
non lo faremo per penso
c'è da mollarmi devo premere z per la
grande siete scemi sì ma ce l'ho fatta
non ci posso credere
minchia strano che non arrivi sushi ma
che culo
io mi piace in finale c'è un finalismo
fermi fermi se finale fermi fermi nel
finale raga non sapevo ci fosse un film
ha visto gioco non avevo idea ci fosse
un finale ma non sapevo dai su c'è un
pacco regalo a giugno
certo sto arrivando l'arco merda no dai
raga sta arrivando l'acqua dai zio c6
zio
no io non ci voglio dai frate frate
frattempo mi devo lanciare la che ci
provo ci devo provare cio provare
[Musica]
no